- C'est vraiment dititititititia
en tant que victimes.OnOnOn vois
nous attaquer, finalement,
dans des procédures judiciaires
- Jean Simard affirme
avoir subi des abuysysysiques
et sexuels lorsqu'enfant
il résidait à l'orphelinat
les Soeurs de la Charité.
Depuis 202l l l se bat pour
obtenir justice dans le cadre
d'un recours collectif
contre
Il espère que les excuses
prononcées jeudi
par le pape François à Québec
feront bouger les choses.
JEAN SIMARD
des actions fortes de la part
des congrégations religieuses.
Là, on tombe vraiment
en processus de réconciliation,
parce qu'il y a de l'action
- Moi, je n'y croyais plus
à ces excuses-là.
est partagé; pour lui,
ce n'est pas suffisant.
SÉBASTIEN RICHARD, p.-p.
victimes, Congr. de Ste-Croix
- Pour nous, les victimes
le pape envoie une directive
extrêmement claire
aux communautés religieuses
et aux diocèses pour que
les recours collecti
- Pierre Bolduc aurait subi
des sévices aun n n d'une autre
congrégation religieuse.
Il croit que le pape aurait dû
aller plenenenenenenenenenenenee
l'Église dans les agressions.
PI B B BOLDUC
- Les agresseurs, OK,
on le sait. Mais, dans mon cas,
lelelelelelelelelelelelelelelel.
Ils étaient au courant,
puis ils le déplaçaient
dans une autre paroisse.
C'est eux autres,
plusieurs victimes alléguées
sont décédées la conclusion
des procédures judiciaires.
24 recours collectifs sont
en cours. 2500 victimes
alléguées C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'Ce
les plaignants souhaitent que
les communautés religieuses
collaborent pour accélérer
le
- C'est quelque chose qui peut
porter fruit si c'est entendu
par les congrégations
religieuses.
espoir. Alors que le pape rentre
au Vatican, c'est peut-êtr
une nouvelle ère qui s'amorce
pour les victimes canadiennes.
Radio-Canada, Québe